نعم بحسب اداره معبر باب الهوى ستدخل
اليوم ايضا ثلاثه وثلاثون شاحنه من
مساعدات الامم المتحده ستدخل عند ظهر هذا
اليوم الى ساحه معبر باب الهوى قبل ان
تتسلمها المنظمات الشريكه الامم المتحده
حاليا وصلت حافله
بخصوص الحركه في الجانب الاخر من الحركه
في هذا المعبر الحافلات التي تقل السوريين
او اللاجئين السوريين الذين كانوا في
تركيا والذين سمح لهم بقضاء اجازه في
سوريا ما تزال هذه الحافلات تصل منذ
الصباح وقد وصل عدد
القادمين من تركيا
3700 شخص بحسب اداره معبر باب الهوى دخلوا
الى الجانب السوري
دخلوا الى الجانب السوري منذ فتح او
السماح لهم بالدخول الى سوريا ومنحهم هذه
الاجازه في الحافله التي كانت قبل قليل
وانطلقت قبل ان نظهر على الهواء مباشره
صعدت الى الحافله وتحدثت مع الركاب بعضهم
لم يزور سوريا منذ وقت طويل كان احدهم
يسكن في اضنه تصدع بيته والان يدخل ليعيش
في منزل اخيه في بلده كفر يحمول هناك ام
كان معها اطفال بعمر ثلاث سنوات قالت
بانهم سيرون سوريا للمره الاولى
طبعا على الرغم من الماسي والصدمات التي
تعرضوا لها والتي يتحدثون عنها الا انهم
يشعرون بشيء من الفرحه عندما يصلون الى
الارض السوريه طبعا بحسب قانون الحمايه
المؤقته الذي يعيش وفقه اللاجئون السوريون
في تركيا فهم لا يستطيعون الدخول الى
سوريا وانما عندما يريدون ان يدخلوا الى
سوريا فهم سوف يتخلون عن هذه الحمايه ولا
يحق لهم العوده الى تركيا مره اخرى بخصوص
ايضا او بخصوص نعود الى القوافل المساعدات
الامويه فقد بلغ عدد الشاحنات التي دخلت
حتى الان
128 شاحنه دخلت
الى معبر باب الهوى وبالاضافه الى
الشاحنات التي دخلت ايضا من معبر باب
السلامه وهناك معبر اخر هو معبر راعي من
المقرر ان تدخل منه الشاحنات لكن حتى
اللحظه لم يستقبل اي مساعدات انسانيه
منسقه الاستجابه تعزوا ذلك الى عرقله
النظام السوري لدخول المساعدات الانسانيه
عبر المعابر البريه طبعا هناك الكثير من
الناس الذين يدخلون ايضا من تركيا يتوجهون
الى مراكز الايواء السكان في مراكز
الايواء طبعا يعيشون معاناه صعبه وظروف
سيئه
بخصوص الهزه الارتداديه التي حدثت ايضا
الليله الماضيه فقد تحدث المركز السوري
للزلازل وقال بان هزه ارضيه بمقياس خمسه
فاصله اربعه درجات حدثت في محافظه ادلب
وحقيقه خلفت خوفا شديدا لدى السكان لان
الناس الذين تصدعت بيوتهم بشكل خفيف ما
زالوا يرفضون الانتقال منها الى مراكز
الايواء المؤقته لكنهم بطبيعه الحال
يتخوفون
ويستشعرون الخطر بسبب التصدعات فيها ولا
شك ان كثير منهم ايضا يريد ان يطمئن على
من تركه في هذه المناطق صهيب الخلف من
معبر باب الهوى شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات